il n'y a pas que j'ai pris des notes
j'ai rien préparé
enfin pas grand chose en tout cas un
petit peu comme dans mon métier j'aime
beaucoup travailler au feeling et puis
je me suis dit dames on monte est en
fête ce soir j'ai fait un petit peu
comme ça j'avais préparé quelque chose
mais ce n'était pas génial non ce que je
suis en train de regarder
c'est un bulletin de notes que ma maman
m'a gentiment accès cet après-midi
novembre décembre 1979 la rédaction 9
un juge français a racheté 1 2 sur 20
l'orthographe cette rame ercis
mathématiques 0 anglais 6 géographie 3
voilà avec j'essaye de lire je ne
découvre quelque part un petit peu en
même temps vous les définitions
fondamentale ne sont pas su les progrès
ne sont donc pas possible
français mathématiques anglais
géographique autant de catastrophes
vous restez s'il vous plaît bon j'ai
quand même quelques prix années 1972
1973 prix de la politesse et de la
vivacité 1973-1974 cris de la taquinerie
et de chant enfin je le découvre aussi
et 74 75 un prix de la taquinerie et de
l'espièglerie donc vous avez compris
vous avez devant vous un contre merci de
rester donc qu'entre j'ai fait une
petite recherche quand même cet après
midi ça vient c'est tiré du latin cancer
cancer crabe donc un crabe a évidemment
quand il veut aller d'un point a à un
point b
là il y va comme ça donc bien sûr ça met
beaucoup plus de temps mais quelque part
vous avez devant vous ce soir un cancre
qui avait un réel et le rêve là je viens
juste de le poser il est là c'est pas
très grand c'est sa mesure 26 cm et se
rêve quand j'étais gamin en fait quand
j'avais 10 ans si je voulais faire de la
gastronomie alors sous quelle forme je
ne savais pas trop ça aurait peut être
cuisinier pâtissier peut-être boucher je
ne savais pas trop jusque avec la
rencontre de mon professeur de français
alors je vais pas le nommer parce qu'il
est toujours de ce membre
par contre je vais vous demander on va
dire monsieur bip donc quand je lèverai
la main on dit pipe
ça va être un petit peu l'ambiance est
sympa donc ce cher monsieur
voilà un jour d'octobre n'avait pas
trouvé mieux que me réprimandé devant
toute la classe
monsieur pasquier vous d'écouter rien
vous êtes absent
vous êtes un cancre vous ferai jamais
rien de bon dans la vie alors bon c'est
clair qu'il n'avait pas tout tort
absent c'est vrai qu'il m'est arrivé
d'en entendre sur le chemin de l'école
de m'arrêter chez le pâtissier du
village j'ai inventé mille histoires en
disant que le professeur n'était pas là
donc je n'avais pas cours et je passais
ma journée chez lui j'écoutais rien ça
aussi il n'avait pas tout tort vu que je
rêvassais plutôt à des gâteaux des
chocolats tout ça est un cancre bon avec
6 sur 20 de moyenne annuelle sais je ne
pouvais pas lui donner tort non plus par
contre à dix ans ça choque c'est très
très choquant quand on vous dit ça
devant toute la classe
je me suis dit je ferai rien de bon dans
la vie ça je me suis dit là où la peur
parce que s'il ya bien quelque chose que
je fais de bien aujourd'hui j'excelle
c'est dans la création de bonnes choses
tout le monde a compris que sissoko
active donc réprimande
j'ai eu une punition et vu que c'était
un cours sur le hérisson
j'ai eu la plus belle punition du monde
il m'a demandé de faire un hérisson en
chocolat et là ça a été la révélation
le soir même je rentre à la maison
j'étais au fond du chocolat j'ai fait
des pipes typique des choses comme ça je
suis revenue le lendemain avec mon rire
ils sont en chocolat pari gagné le
problème c'est que quand on est un
contre ben il ya beaucoup de portes qui
se ferment et bah pour moi ma foi le
système scolaire voulait plus de moi
on m'avait classé un petit peu dans les
les gentils mais sans plus moi
mais là mes parents c'est une rencontre
qu'ils ont rencontré le directeur d'une
école hôtelière à noirmoutier ça se
trouve en vendée qu'il a à dire mes
parents mais s'il veut faire de la
gastronomie il faut lui donner cette
chance
moi je le prends dans mon école le
problème c'est que j'avais 3 ans d'
avance j'avais que 13 ans donc petit on
m'a fait des baisses de cuisine sur
mesure
hélas le directeur m'a donné trois mois
pour avoir en tout cas la moyenne ces
trois mois ont suffi à ce que je sois
premier de la classe health a duré
pendant trois ans s'en est suivi
l'obtention du cfc cuisinier après j'ai
bourlingué pas mal dans les cuisines
entre l'angleterre l'allemagne et la
suisse
enfin le valais plus particulièrement
j'ai rencontré ma femme bagnarde sapho
mérite quand même sous le nom quand même
ça fait longtemps que ça dure
elle est aussi issu du milieu de la
restauration est bien un jour on s'est
dit mais si on reprenait notre
entreprise
on va devenir indépendant on fera un
petit peu ce qu'on veut fini les ors
machin on ouvre notre entreprise donc on
est parti à la recherche d'un
établissement un restaurant sur sion on
avait trouvé
jusqu'au jour où j'ai reçu un coup de
téléphone d'un petit papy nougatier à
crans-montana me dit écoute david des
restaurants c'est bien beau mais sur
sion il ya déjà 50 reprend mon
entreprise à nous gagner c'est bien joli
mais moi le nouvel j'y connais rien et
là mon épouse me dit mais écoute c'est
génial c'est une belle opportunité si ça
va bien aujourd'hui c'est que en bois
français et moi je vous dis non non le
double à la confiserie j'y connais rien
du tout je suis cuisinier
donc c'est non lundi mais c'est pas
grave on va apprendre et puis on verra
bien on prend le risque d'ailleurs
puisqu'on risqués et là j'ai quand même
eu le dernier mot j'ai dit oui chérie
il paraît que ça marche comme ça dans le
val de bagnes donc s'en suit la visite
des locaux vous explique pas vétuste
la pousse va pas tomber les petites
bêtes à papa qu'on semble très très
vétuste il fallait être un petit peu fou
pour reprendre l'entreprise une
formation très accélérée du métier de
nous gagner un passage devant le notaire
en signe puis nous voilà en novembre
2005 propriétaire d'une galerie
la belle affaire le problème c'est qu'on
ne s'improvise pas nous gâter du jour au
lendemain c'est très compliqué et que
malgré tout il fallait quand même servir
le peu de clients ils poussaient encore
la porte je dois vous dire quelque chose
c'est que si quelqu'un que j'aime elle
satisfait je suis jamais content pensez
bien ça peut être mieux et penser mieux
ça doit être encore encore mieux hélas
le nougat au bout de quelques mois mais
ça m'a saoulé c'est toujours la même
recette c'est toujours coupées des cubes
mais vraiment rien de créatifs et moi je
suis un créatif et là je vais repenser à
ce qu'a dit monsieur je suis dit mais à
ce moment là il m'a dit que je ferai
jamais rien de bon dans la vie et je me
suis dit mais si on est là aujourd'hui
en fait c'est là que je vais pouvoir
m'exprimer c'est là que je vais je
pouvoir commencer à vivre et ce hérisson
en chocolat à l'époque ce qui m'avait
beaucoup plus de travail et ça j'ai dit
ben on va faire du chocolat est bon là
aussi je métier de chocolatier c'est un
truc super compliqué et je connaissais
rien premier fournisseur je l'appelle
j'ai dit est ce qu'il faut mettre du
vernis dans le chocolat pour faire
briller
il s'est dit lui à mon avis dans six
mois n'est plus là mais ça fait quand
même 27 ans je suis en valais donc j'ai
un sacré caractère et on ya cru on a
bossé jusqu'à 20 heures
jour sept jours sur sept on y croyait et
puis l'a gentiment les gens pousser la
porte du chocolat c'est sympa ça il n'y
avait pas trop à crans montana
d'ailleurs j'ai une petite anecdote il
ya une dame
il ya deux mois qui me dit c'est très
marrant parce que en fait quand vous
avez commencé il ya huit ans nous on
venait par pitié pour des jeunes qui
commence et on va leur acheter de la
marchandise pour les soutenir
elle dit aujourd'hui je traverse je
change de trottoir j'ai vite je regarde
pas beaucoup de boutiques tellement je
suis accro donc ça c'est plutôt plutôt
sympa on fait du chocolat mais c'est
vrai quand on s'est dit on fait du
chocolat en train du chocolat haut de
gamme moi je veux pas qu'on que nos
chocolats ressemble à son jeu trouver en
grandes surfaces ont fait du chocolat
haut de gamme des produits très soigné
et je pense que mon métier de cuisinier
vu que j'ai pas été formaté par une part
la formation de chocolatiers mon métier
de cuisinier m'a permis de prendre une
autre direction d'avoir une autre vision
du chocolat et il ya une chose qui est
sûre c'est que de toute manière je fais
ce que je veux je m'adapte pas au client
c'est le client qui s'adapte à mort le
client et la khl a acheté ce que moi
j'ai envie de faire c'est tout et comme
ça une petite surprise
enfin il ya six ans j'ai pas créer un
chocolat parce que c'est des choses qui
se font mais j'ai sorti un petit
chocolat en forme de demi sphère et là
vous avez une belle surprise sous votre
chaise à gauche ou à regarder
un petit chocolat moi je ne veux pas
tout de suite s'il vous plaît première
aussi c'est tout nouveau c'est pas en
boutique
donc vous êtes les premiers à déguster
on n'a pas mis de servier pour cracher
voilà la petite sphère elle est là je
vous dis pas parce que c'est manger le
pas encore bien loin qu'ils ont mangé
déjà donc cette petite sphère
quand j'ai sorti ça on a mis 100
boutiques les gens pousser la porte de
la boutique disait mais c'est quoi c'est
pas du chocolat c'est nous on veut pas
de ça ça ressemble à des smarties le
flop le flop complet mais je pense que
vous vous voyez très mal dans le noir
mais il est très jeune mais moi quelque
part ce petit chocolat j'y croyais je
trouvais ça joli un petit dôme c'était
brillant coloré génie ma foi moi je fais
ce que j'ai envie le client il a peint
s'adapter et ben ces mêmes clients six
ans après reviennent à la boutique et
achètent des boîtes que de ses demi
soeurs on en fabrique aujourd'hui de
tonnes donc je crois que quand on a une
idée même la plus farfelue il faut y
croire et continuer maintenant on va
peut-être le manger parce qu'il va
fondre dans les mains et après je vais
vous donner un petit peu ma - comment je
vois le chocolat je vous dis rien
arranger le
ça peut-être un petit peu chauffé dans
la salle mais c'est pas fondu alors
quand vous le manger voici voilà c'est
ma vision du cheveu l'a d'abord et à
l'abricot
ma femme est valaisanne donc abricots
après j'aime bien les contrastes donc
l'acidité de l'abricot après derrière il
ya de la mangue
j'ai donné une petite pointe ça j'aime
beaucoup je pense si vous le sentez cd
safran ça va peut-être venir par après
en chauffant dans le panier et ça c'est
ma vision du chocolat c'est vraiment
quelque part ce que j'ai envie de faire
je le fais alors on me demande souvent
mais comment mais je me rends compte que
j'ai oublié les slides mais d'ailleurs
on ne l'a pas donnée c'est pas grave on
n'a pas donné la petite manette pour
assez que ça passe tout seul c'est beau
le progrès ok ma vision du chocolat
voilà c'est ça c'est je fais ce que j'ai
envie on me demande souvent mais comment
tu crées tons chocolat
pourquoi tu fais un chocolat abricots
manque safran et pourquoi pas un
chocolat juste à l'abricot
j'en sais rien je peux pas vous
expliquer c'est comme ça ça va bien dans
ma tête et je fais alors souvent ça
passe par quand même quelques essais
parce qu'il ya comme toujours des petits
ajustements
et puis ça peut être surprenant on a
fait des chocolats aux poivrons on a
fait des chocolats à la courge
on a fait des chocolats à l'olive et je
crois que les gens ils aiment bien il
aime bien découvrir c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les gens voyagent de plus
en plus sont prêts à découvrir plein de
choses et puis ben pour pour moi c'est
un vrai bonheur donc voilà en fait la
petite histoire ça marche bien ça roule
l'entreprise ça marche bien sauf que il
ya deux ans - il manquait quelque chose
il y avait quelque part je suis
cuisinier puis dans le monde très fermé
des chocolatiers j'étais un petit peu un
parvenu donc il me manquait un statut
est là en avril 2012
une belle opportunité les championnats
suisses de chocolat
je veux voir ma femme très lentement
y aller tranquille j'ai chéri écoute il
ya les championnats suisses de chocolat
moi je vais me lancer
l'amdi non un billet coûte l'entreprise
aléas train de monter tu vas te rajouter
du stress et c'est très dangereux
merci beaucoup pour alors ça c'est un
petit peu ce qu'on ferait un pacte mais
voilà ça c'est en fait ce qu'on veut la
grenouille de pâques le porte crayons de
pâques noël du ski chaudron pack
collection autour du monde ça a été un
petit clin d'oeil aux championnats du
monde en corée on va y revenir
donc je lui dit écoute championnat
suisse je veux y aller et là bien sûr
elle me dit mais coûte non beaucoup trop
de travail beaucoup de stress
là on n'y va pas ça va mettre
l'entreprise en péril mais moi j'étais
convaincu que pour moi personnellement
ça allait me faire évoluer et pour
l'entreprise aussi ça allait être
quelque chose qui allait booster la
chose et j'ai dit non mais écoute je
veux y aller
hélas elle qui a eu le dernier mot et
m'a dit oui chérie comme ça et donc mais
ma voix la partie au championnat suisse
donc alors je vous explique pas entre la
production pour la boutique les
entraînements pour les championnats
suisses fallait jongler entre tout ça
est quelque part moi qui aime beaucoup
les sphères c'est rigolo de jongler et
bien ma foi le 21 janvier 2013
les résultats tombent du champion suisse
qui top au génial qu'ils connaissaient
rien qui connaissez rien il ya huit ans
que je suis tellement passionné et puis
je vais dans mes idées et puis je fonce
et puis j'ai raflé quatre prix sur six
j'étais super déterminer sauf que quand
on est champion suisse ça implique une
participation aux championnats du monde
donc on remet le couvert et alors là
c'est une autre paire de manches parce
que ça a été six mois de préparation
voilà ça c'est aujourd'hui à l'atelier
tactique
pardon si je veux un petit peu vite
c'est un peu le stress ça c'est lé cas
avec rick à sion donc pour le
championnat suisse
les championnats suisses et on va
arriver
la pièce ont travaillé sur un thème qui
s'appelait l architecture du goût ça
veut rien dire
trempez en suisse c'est vrai donc il ya
des photos il ya le dit c'est vraiment
vrai ça peut paraître très étonnant
parce que il ya des gens qui travaillent
toute une vie et quelque part qui sont
pas arrivés alors c'est peut-être un peu
prétentieux mais je trouve qu'il faut
dire qu'ils sont pas arrivés au niveau
où on arrivait en même pas neuf ans et
ça c'est parce que je pense que on veut
pas suivre le chemin qui est tracé on
fait ce qu'on a envie de faire et
automatiquement on est différent des
autres
donc voilà au championnat du monde 19
candidats les meilleurs de chaque pays
il faut pas oublier qu'au départ on
était quatre cents personnes dans cette
compétition donc arriver au championnat
du monde
parmi les dix autres prêts à en découdre
à coups de sculptures de petits
chocolats et le niveau était très très
haut il ya des pays qui se prépare
pendant des mois et des mois qui ont des
gros gros moyens derrière
donc quand on arrive le petit suisse
derrière malgré qu'on soit le pays du
chocolat
il faut s'accrocher eh bien ma foi j'ai
quand même décrocher j'ai été classé
parmi les 10 meilleurs chocolatiers au
monde donc c'est ça c'était la
présentation du gâteau mais on avait un
globe à faire en chocolat tu as tic le
génie du goût avec une personne qui vous
faire un ted l'année passée qui
s'appelle et vic line et c'est elle qui
m'a beaucoup aidé pour la sculpture
parce que la sculpture
on est vraiment encore dans un autre
travail du chocolat on est dans de la 3d
tout c'est très compliqué donc j'ai eu
beaucoup de soutien de la part de l'inrs
et donc je me suis classé parmi les 10
meilleurs chocolatiers au monde
et je suis dans le timing est donc mais
j'en arrive à un petit peu à la
conclusion je pense que quand on a des
idées
quoi qu'il se passe quoi qu'il arrive
faut y croire
et puis faut continuer faut continuer
puis je pense que un jour ou l'autre de
toute manière ça ça finit par payer
on a encore beaucoup de travail faut se
dire que enfin moi c'est ce que je me
dis et toute notre équipe c'est ce qu'on
dit c'est que c'est jamais gagné s'est
jamais acquis et tous les jours il faut
se remettre en cause il faut continuer
il faut continuer il faut innover
j'aurais quand même un dernier mot pour
monsieur nana je veux dire son nom
c'est monsieur chartier qui un jour
d'octobre 1979 m'avait mis un grand coup
de pied dans le bipe